hey everybody its Charlie we got to talk
about this mystery Submariner movie that
Marvel is cooking up for phase 3 or
phase 4 what a surprise they're
announcing all these new Marvel projects
when they're dropping infinity war
spider-man homecoming is getting ready
to happen
guardians of the galaxy so they're going
to be all kinds of Marvel movie videos
coming if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there's a Marvel giveaway going on at
the end of the video that I'll explain
but the deal is is they're supposedly a
mystery name or movie called the
Submariner that's getting ready to shoot
later this year in Hawaii around the
same place that they're shooting the
Inhumans TV series some of you may have
seen some of the animated versions of
the characters and different TV shows
that Marvel is done this is going to be
born I am from the world that needs to
see life just outside your window we
have ensured your solution for century
but we know suffering no longer know I
am named ruler a kingdom of Atlantis
your time in the Sun is over I just want
to assure you all that this has
absolutely nothing to do with the
experimental explosives I've been
inventing in the lab
you're doing what dr. Richards
we're having a name well goodbye
[Music]
the 10 really important things you need
to know is that this information comes
from a production tracking service that
also broke the news about the inhuman
shooting in Hawaii they track all the
projects that go into development under
their working title so number 9 the
Inhumans TV show that's filming in
Hawaii is not the same thing is this
Submariner project that doesn't mean
that they're not connected it just means
that the working titles for both of
these projects are different meaning
that they're separate productions they
never shoot anything with the real name
of the movie or the TV show just to
maintain an air of secrecy so for
instance thor ragnarok shot with the
working title creature report so that's
what it said on all the scripts all the
trucks all the production equipment just
to throw people off a little bit
although everybody knows when they see
Chris Hemsworth walking around with
Mjolnir what kind of a movie they're
getting ready to shoot so the working
title for the Inhumans TV series is just
called Project next this name or project
is called the Submariner number eight
the Submariner name is only ever used to
refer to Namor that's his alias it's
like calling Tony Stark Iron Man you
wouldn't shoot some random Marvel
project and call it Iron Man if it
didn't have anything to do with Tony
Stark so whatever it is wherever it's
going to drop whether it's a TV show or
a movie it's going to be based on name
Wars character but because of who name
Wars character is a lot of people were
wondering if Marvel's going to change
him and turn him into an inhuman and
it'll have something to do with this
Inhumans TV show but also kind of be a
separate thing it could also exist in
that same way with the Marvel movies to
where it's relatively self-contained
kind of like Doctor Strange is
self-contained so if it doesn't work out
they can just fold everything up and put
it in the corner and nobody has to
remember it number 7 the name itself
Submariner is named after this poem
called The Rime of the Ancient Mariner
but Namor is actually taken from Roman
it's literally just Roman backwards so
he's named after the Roman Empire but
number 6 the even bigger thing is that
he is Marvel's first mutant now not
because he's the oldest mutant on the
planet in the context of the story it's
because he's the first Marvel character
to debut in the comics as a mutant he
debuted in 1939
during a comic called motion picture
funnies weekly number one and I know
that sounds like the most serious thing
ever very grounded in reality but the
story that he debuted is super hardcore
it's a simple revenge based plot that
explains both how Namor is a hero to his
people but a villain to the surface
dwellers so he attacks this research
vessel when it comes near Atlantis
killing the crew bringing their bodies
home as trophies freaking hardcore
considering the title of the comic is
motion picture funnies but the way they
explain the twist is that his mother
taught him to hate surface dwellers
because the long ago they came to
Antarctica where Atlantis was conducted
research experiments that killed a lot
of Atlanteans so these are revenge
killings he's just protecting his people
but in a really hardcore way number five
there are a lot of Aquaman comparisons
the child of two worlds they're both
kings of Atlantis Namor started first in
the comics so make of that what you will
but the reason both Marvel and DC can
use Atlantis is because it's a public
domain idea it would be like trying to
copyright America or Europe in the
comics could you even imagine Marvel or
DC going to each other and saying you
can't use America in the comics because
we used it first
it'd be ridiculous number four the main
reason why Marvel has not pursued a name
or movie in the past is mostly because
of movie rights issues in the fact that
the character is not that popular he's
not even that popular in the comics he's
very big but he's just not one of the
marquee Avengers characters
[Music]
when Marvel started making their phase 1
movies they had already sold the rights
off to Universal they just got those
back seven months ago so now they can do
a name or movie anytime they want but
they already have so many movies on the
schedule that name or just is not a big
priority for them which is why you
haven't heard a lot about until now with
this mystery movie that's getting ready
to shoot in Hawaii
way back when Universal still had the
rights they tried to make a version of
the movie with Christopher Columbus that
never made it off the ground before they
got the rights there was even the Saban
entertainment that's right Power Rangers
Haim Saban tried to make a version of
the movie in 1997 but it didn't happen
cut to now when it looks like we might
actually see a version of that happening
but number three this is really cool he
has got huge history with Black Panthers
character another big movie that Marvel
is in the middle of shooting right now
in the comics they even update a name
Wars backstory to make it closer to
black panther Canon so originally his
father was a researcher on a vessel
studying in Antarctica he fell in love
with an Atlantean princess in out pops
Namor nine months later
so later Marvel redcon that just a
little bit in the updated version of the
story is that that research vessel that
came to Antarctica was looking for
vibranium deposits vibranium we know
most of the vibranium in the world
exists under Wakanda so everybody wants
it more recently in the comics name wars
been more of a straight-up villain for
black panther so also graying the line
number two he's a founding member of the
loominatee Marvel is slowly moving
towards Illuminati type things in The
Avengers movies which is a big deal but
his inclusion on the team is mostly
because of the scope of his domain he's
also really powerful but just like Black
Panther he is the king of a great body
of people making him a very important
person in the world the flip side to
that is that he also spun out of the
Illuminati and helped form the Cabal the
evil version of the Illuminati Sandoz
Maximus the mad
Terrax Corvus glaive Proxima midnight
black swan in maker their first base was
actually locate
in the ruins of Wakanda after a series
of attacks from Namor in the atlanteans
as well as incursions from other
realities so that was part of a bigger
story leading up to Marvel's Secret Wars
you don't have to read it in the comics
but it was part of Nemours art in
becoming this really great villain who
was trying to protect reality but at the
same time doing really terrible things
so number one that's why they're going
to have to change a lot about name Wars
character because he is a mutant in the
comics they can't do mutants in the
movies they would have to make him
enhance that's the term that Marvel has
been using if they don't want to make
him an inhuman like Scarlet Witch and
spider-man they have biologically-based
powers but they call them enhanced it's
just based on the idea of Kevin Feige
not wanting to totally commit to the
idea of Inhumans in the MCU yet so it's
sort of their funny way around that
problem in his backstory with Black
Panther is going to have to be a little
bit different because the Black Panther
movie is already introducing so many
characters so many ideas that they don't
want to overstuff it so to try to
explain his backstory with Namor would
just be way too much so if they're going
to do name or in the movies eventually
they're going to have to streamline his
backstory the same way they're
streamlining Captain Marvel's backstory
so that it's just a little bit simpler
and it doesn't bump up against copyright
issues but let me know in the comments
what do you think is going on here is
this going to be connected to the
Inhumans TV show or do you think that
this is going to be something for the
MCU but what's going to be happening
next is is the embargo for the Logan
movie is up so I'll be doing a video for
why it is the best x-men movie not
including Deadpool of all time Logan is
the kind of movie that will make you
feel like Fox knows what they're doing
like when they did Deadpool okay they
can actually make really good x-men
movies this is totally going to turn you
around on their new strategy for the way
they do movies
so that'll post Saturday but it'll be
non spoilery so don't worry because the
movie is not going to be out for a while
but giveaway stuff so I'm giving away
copies of the Doctor Strange DVD blu-ray
digital download whatever you guys want
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video just like the other giveaways that
I do thank you so much for watching I'll
see you guys in that next video while
you wait for that to post you can click
here to watch that black panther teaser
again
and you can click here to learn about
the new things that they revealed about
Star Wars the last Jedi